la rentrée c'est toujours un jour très
particulier il y avait sûrement beaucoup
d'élèves qui avaient une petite angoisse
matin en reprenant le chemin de l'école
pour les tout petits qui entre en
maternelle c'est vraiment une nouvelle
expérience qui commence et c'est
toujours très émouvant ce matin a fool
griesheim près de strasbourg
il y avait beaucoup de sourires et
presque pas de pleurs stéphanie la
fuente antioche stahlschmidt l arrivée
dans la cour le pas et décidé et les
mines réjouies
mais une fois devant la porte de la
classe les premières hésitations
apparaissent heureusement la maîtresse
n'est pas loin pour rassurer un
changement c'est un peu dur aujourd'hui
multi verra ça ira tous les jours à
venir
une déferlante de bisous et juste après
avoir donner les dernières consignes
les parents s'éclipse discrètement pour
laisser l'enfant et puis partir le plus
rapidement possible pour éviter
qui pense pas encore mais en même temps
c'est que connaît l'école c'est qu'ils
sont dans un environnement sympathique
qui va les aider à conduire il était
temps pour lui
mais grandir c'est parfois difficile
une fois ces petits incidents de
démarrage passé chacun prend ses marques
et au final tous sont heureux d'être
enfin à l'école voulait voir mes copains
de la récréation
aujourd'hui seule la moitié des petits
ont commencé l'école une rentrée
échelonnée pour une adaptation en
douceur autre mesure la découverte de
l'école dès le mois de juin alors qu'ils
ont déjà eu un premier contact avec
l'école pour moi de juin ne serait-ce
qu'une matinée lent à la rentrée se fait
vraiment de façon beaucoup plus sereine
chansons dessins goûter après une
première matinée bien chargée pour les
nouveaux écoliers cet après-midi ce sera
l'heure d'une sieste bien méritée